right
[Music]
now
foreign
[Music]
so good morning good morning good
morning everyone
good morning everyone on Old campus and
watching us around the country around
the world and around Yale itself
my name is Penny Lawrence
and I've been at Yale a long long time
longer than I wish to say
and I'm here with my friend burji I'm a
senior advisor at the University and
Virgie good morning folks I'm burgie
Howard I'm one of the associate vice
presidents for student life here and I
work with undergraduate and graduate
students and I'm very happy to see you
all as we start to assemble here on the
yard and getting ready for folks to
watch our perception today
so you might ask what it is we're doing
here
and it occurred to uh several people
that it might be nice while everyone is
waiting because the wait is long
to have somebody who talked a little bit
about commencement about the history of
commencement about what you're seeing
today where people are where the
students are and exactly what is going
on because it's a bit of a mystery if
you've never seen it before if you've
never seen a Yale commencement
so that's what we're going to do I mean
you know some of you have been to other
university commencements uh I would say
Yale is kind of special there there are
unique Traditions there's some things
that you you may be familiar with but if
you've never been to a university
commitment commencement you're in for a
treat because it is uh kind of chaos
that comes together like an orchestra we
hear our Orchestra tuning up here to our
left
um but then when they come together the
symphony is actually really quite
beautiful
will say that we know
we know especially the people who are
sitting here or who are watching in
places around the campus it is a long
weekend
often people have come from a long
distance and it is an easy travel and
you know having this event is really I
think it's like holding a wedding in
your backyard you know you've invited
too many people
and um you're not sure the backyard will
hold them all but everybody wants it to
be Sensational and wonderful exactly and
we are fortunate that Mother Nature has
done her part so we have a lovely day
and so if you're watching from out of
state or out of country it is going to
be a lovely day perfect day for a
University commencement so we're very
fortunate in that regard so this wedding
will go on if you want to listen to us
you can and if not you can mute us and
do something else while you're waiting
the actual ceremony the procession will
begin much earlier but the actual
ceremony is probably only begins at 11
o'clock but there's a lot of heraldry
and a lot of marching and a lot of
things before that so Bergie I think
before we begin
it might be nice to say some thank yous
oh very much so yeah this this event
cannot happen without hundreds of people
uh all around the university really
coming out I mean even just the the
setup this week getting all these chairs
I came out into the yard and our
facility staff making sure that we had
all the chairs and banners and flags in
place it's quite amazing to see how
quickly we turn around from the end of
the semester to getting ready for kind
of multiple days of major events
first of all to all
to all children your students your
family members we know it's a long way
and it's not always easy and they deeply
appreciate it in this moment of their
lives and we also want to say thank you
to
all the facilities staff
who work so hard to set up this stage
the Landscaping people Jose in Ura and
all the people who make the campus look
beautiful the operations managers across
the whole entire uh
Campus Dining Hospitality mining uh
housekeeping you know everyone who's you
know the the amount of mulch and mowing
that happens in these final days
particularly after a heavy rainstorm to
make sure all the chairs were dry
yesterday for the uh Baccalaureate
ceremony in the morning uh all of these
pieces where folks are really working
very hard to make this as seamless as
possible for you our guests and for our
graduates so once again to everybody out
dining staff Rafi
ending Halls that the students love so
much and all of the people across the
campus thank you so very very much for
everything that you've done to make this
day happen this is definitely a team
effort it's a team effort
uh so let's maybe start and talk a
little bit about what this day is what
is commencement
I think everybody knows that
it's a beginning it's a beginning for
many students and it's an ending at the
same time it's a culmination of years of
work
in in the professional schools many many
years of work but it's also a day for
Yale in which
really the only day in which we see
representatives from across the
university come together
yeah it is it's special I mean you know
I think uh the university you know we
started with Yale College and yesterday
there was a focus on the undergraduate
college but really when you look at all
of our graduate and professional schools
coming together and it's one of the
wonderful things about this ceremony
that we're bringing the entire
university community together it is one
of these opportunities where students in
different schools and colleges get have
this opportunity to interact and and
hear about and witness the scholarship
and celebrate each other and so uh it's
one of the exciting moments for many of
our students and I know that are some of
our graduate students that I work with
have been really looking forward to this
day and they are cheering for their
friends in nursing and cheering for
their friends in medicine and public
health and uh and then celebrating with
their their cohort and classmates
teen schools Yale has 14 Schools and if
I miss any Virgie will help me I will
try to fill in some gaps so we'll start
with a medical school the School of
Public Health the School of Nursing the
four schools of the Arts it's
interesting to know that Yale is I
believe the only private university that
has four schools of the arts art
architecture drama and music that's
seven then we have law yes
we have School of Management
um we also have uh well obviously Yale
College but we have The Graduate School
of Arts and Sciences which is our big
one
um and then our newest School
the Jackson School the school of globe
Global Affairs School in the environment
School of the environment and the School
of Engineering which is interesting
because many years ago Yale did have a
School of Engineering and then for a
good time engineering was incorporated
into the uh Sheffield into the FAS into
the faculty of Arts and Sciences and now
it is a separate school again with Jeff
rock as its Dean so uh I think we've
covered them all we've got all 14. yeah
uh Public Health nursing music yeah I
think we got the list medicine law
Graduate School of Arts and Sciences
Global Affairs environment drama
Divinity art and architecture that's a
big university and today you'll see
graduates from all of them and faculty
from all of them
so when this arena is full
and those of you who are watching
online
will also be able to see this right in
front of us first will be the faculty
right so we'll have the faculty sitting
in front of us
and in back of them will be the
undergraduates right here
and then to the left
and to the right will be the graduate
schools right yeah professional schools
graduate schools and then Arts and
Sciences nursing in the center and the
smaller schools as you go back so if you
folks watch
screens and online you can see
once it begins
and beginning and in the procession
we'll be able to identify for you by the
color of what they're wearing a lot of
the schools
and many of the schools the schools will
have a kind of a standard Bearer and so
the the that Banner will lead that group
in uh but each of the the robes in
regalia will identify the schools and
then we will try to point them out as we
uh as we see them in the procession so
that you can see where your students are
in the procession but they are coming
you know like the tribes Gathering
they're moving from different parts of
Campus getting ready for the procession
right now I know that Yale broadcast and
we didn't thank them but we should thank
Yale broadcast and Yale audio visual
they will try to show as many students
as they possibly can of course they
cannot cannot show everybody but once
the procession starts they will start so
let's say a word about where people are
now where are students now
so students in the undergraduate
colleges are starting to they're
Gathering their college Deans and heads
are starting to get them organized and
so they are then lining up so that they
move towards the cross campus area so
the area out in front of the main
Memorial Library and they will be lined
up and they generally come in each year
the the order changes but the
undergraduate colleges will line up and
they will come along the walk that will
come towards NOAA Porter gate
so first the undergraduates are in their
colleges they're lining up and they're
coming to cross campus and what is the
atmosphere like on Cross campus it is
Happy chaos
um you know folks are just really
excited to see each other uh you know
they are visiting they're checking out
their finery making sure that they're
you know uh regalia is uh on straight
and that the you know hair is pinned up
and everything else they're taking a ton
of photographs so you can see a shot
here of uh the new reporter gate and you
can see uh some of the faculty there on
the right Gathering and uh some of the
folks from Yale College and you can see
the pink uh there from the School of
Music
um as they are they're kind of getting
themselves organized
I see some of the colleges as well
um that's nice that they're showing that
at the the uh the
procession of the president and the
corporation and the honorary degree
people will come first to that gate and
March out and then the Yale College
Dean's office will come in back and uh
we'll we'll talk a little bit more about
that in a minute I want to say a word
first about the history of commencement
oh sure yeah and uh so
the first commencement in New Haven was
in 1718 Yale was founded in 1701
but no one was sure it was going to be
in New Haven or whether it was going to
be in Saybrook for a very long time and
Hartford was making a big play for Yale
and by 1718 it wasn't yet all set but in
1718 the people in New Haven were trying
to confirm that this is where Yale would
be okay and the first commencement took
place in Center Church which is on the
green okay right down there on the green
so the the whole this very small number
of graduates marched to Center Church
and had their commencement there
eventually
uh it Yale built a chapel and it moved
to the chapel and Battelle Chapel right
here
held the commencement
for many years and in about 1903 it got
too big for Battelle Chapel so they
moved it to to Woolsey Hall
and of course then it got too big we
keep growing which is a wonderful side
of progress but this idea of you know
commencements I think in the early days
were very you know they're heavily
religious services and
um you know very simple and but we have
gotten more elaborate as in particularly
as we've started to have the influence
of kind of the European Europe uh
educational system so you know you like
to talk a little bit about the robes and
the regalia that come with scholarship
uh that have been embraced by Yale and
other universe and American universities
yeah I think it is it is worth saying
something about the robes the Caps the
banners all of the heraldry that Yale
has and by the way Yale has a lot of
heraldry and it has a lot of flags it
has a lot of banners it has a lot of
pins and it has a lot of now stalls and
um we'll say a word about what all those
things mean so
um as you can see I'm wearing a a
crimson robe even though I've been at
Yale for many many many years teaching
here and being an administrator here you
wear the robe and you wear the hood
of well you wear the robe of the school
that you have your PhD from correct the
color many robes are black undergraduate
robes are Black Masters roads Divinity
robes
and
um
you know the hoods will it signify
obviously the degree and so you know in
my case uh the light blue is the color
of education and then I have a cardinal
color which is from the school that I
attended yeah so
and the inside of the hood is usually
the school that you have attended I'm
wearing a Harvard gown because my PhD
was from Harvard
we'd like to refer to them as the school
up north the school up north you can
hear colleges getting ready and marching
out of their Gates they're yelling and
screaming with happy it looks like the
uh
branfordians are gathering over there
yeah and they're on their way to to uh
cross campus exactly so um I'm wearing a
a red gown and the Yale color is blue
you will see a lot of blue gowns today
PhD gowns the PHD hoods are all blue
dark blue dark blue within depending on
what your degree will have a different
color in the insert on the insert right
and
um the other colors for other schools
and they're a good way to identify your
students or your people who are Marching
uh is according to the color of their
Hood so everybody from public health
will be wearing a salmon pink everybody
who's getting a PhD will be wearing a
blue there is a little bit of
complication in that there are three
different Blues we like blue here yeah
so yeah you can't have too much well the
PHD hoods are blue
and the hoods from the new Jackson
School are peacock blue and the hoods
from the School of Management are
sapphire blue
so there are three different blues that
we have to recognize it isn't always
easy yeah don't hold me to determining
between peacock and Sapphire I know
that's why I look for the law students
because I can tell that that deep forest
green I know
uh yeah I think it's worth saying how
many students from each School are here
because you'll see long long marches so
the the biggest school will be The
Graduate School of Arts and Sciences
which includes I think engineering and
that's 745 people that's a lot of that
is an armada and you'll hear them when
they come in of course Yale College is
the biggest of all that's over 1500
people
and then um I think the school of
management management is very big it has
561.
um and then is it public health or
medicine I think is the next public
health has 383. that's very very nice
that a lot of Public Health people are
going out into this thing you know it's
been interesting Public Health has
really kind of grown uh in recent years
and I think you know given what we've
all been living through the past few
years people see the importance of
Public Health and I think many of our
students have been called to to study in
this area in large part because of what
they've seen and how this plays out in
people's lives so it's a it's a
testament to them so 383 students is
impressive nursing 120 music 111 all
instruments and boys
medicine 210 law 243 these graduate
schools are smaller for example than
some other institutions that but they
are very great graduate schools and the
students love that cohort size that they
get to know the faculty they get to know
their classmates and they that so much
learning happens from those around them
that I think that that's one of the
values of some of the the intimacy of
some of these schools so the new school
of
11 graduates which a brand new school
the environment has 134
drama has 55. divinity
which will be wearing Scarlet hoods one
of Yale's oldest schools will have 119.
62 people from the School of Art and 99
from the School of Architecture
that's fantastic so I mean I'm always
kind of amazed when I you know have an
opportunity to either meet students from
the school or go into these spaces and
just to see how you know that for you
know many of the undergraduates they
live in the undergraduate colleges and
they kind of move here on Old campus you
know whereas these graduate students
have their own worlds and so when you
step into the School of Architecture
you're kind of transported or going to
the School of Art and seeing the studios
and the you know I had an opportunity to
sit in on a critique a couple years ago
where student artwork and just the
interplay between students and faculty
in those settings and so it is really
wonderful to kind of see and experience
the 14 different yales as we look at it
from broadly and then even within the
undergraduates 14 different experiences
within the residential colleges
so we said this was one Yale people
coming together you know on this day of
Celebration this is a celebration for
students of course it's a celebration
for families very much so and it's also
really a celebration of learning that is
in a way what a commencement is it is a
gathering
in which we also celebrate in a sense
ourselves yeah and it the place of plays
in learning and in contributing to the
higher societies to society
so everything that uh you see here in a
way is a celebration of that and that's
like giving a big party a big
celebrating party and it is of course
celebrating the graduates it's
celebrating the families who made it
possible for them to do this very much
so it's but it's also celebrating the
university as a whole and learning
um you know even yesterday so the day
proceeding uh the university ceremony
um various events are happening but here
on Old campus where we are now yesterday
morning we had the University
Baccalaureate ceremony and in the
afternoon the undergraduate college has
our class day and class day when it
first began was you know that small you
know 100 graduates gathered in a circle
kind of talking about their memories of
their experience at Yale College it is
now morphed into this larger kind of
prize day and celebration and laughter
and speeches but again it's still that's
that that sharing of the experience that
commonality of the experience and you
know one of the things that I'm always
kind of taken by is uh there's a moment
where uh the students are invited to
um acknowledge the people who supported
them to get here yeah and in fact the
senior class inserted a car note card as
one final opportunity for every senior
to share a note of thanks with someone
who's made a difference and you know the
student said this could be a faculty
member this could be a parent a
grandparent it could be the person who
saved a seat for you in class when
you're running late so you know those
levels of of giving thanks and
celebration are part of this weekend
so yesterday was you know
it's a more formal day yes it's more
formal and Yale's commencement ceremony
is very formal and as all of you know
right after this ceremony which is a
ceremony for everyone people will go to
the schools and to the residential
colleges and that is where they will
receive their diplomas right you know
and those ceremonies tend to have a
little bit more personality to them this
is a very ritualistic very formalistic
event
and um
let's talk a little bit
we'll talk about honorary degrees and
who's getting them in a moment but
perhaps first we'll talk a little bit
more about heraldry and the flags and
the pins and the robes so we talked
about the robes I can also tell you
about the Caps I'm holding here an eight
cornered cap and those are worn by phds
six cornered caps are we're Masters
Master students and then the traditional
one that you the four corner tap that
you see you know is for undergraduates
The Bachelors of Arts and Sciences
there is actually a board of academic
regalia
I don't know where they are there's
always a board there's a board and they
decide they coordinate the colors of of
the hoods and of the gowns and they you
know they say what is legal and what is
not legal they say that the eight Corner
caps are for PhD they say that the light
blue are for Education they say that the
Crimson robe is Harvard's so you're
you're telling me I'm illegal with some
of my
apparently we are illegal oh yeah wow so
it says that uh the I think the board of
academic uh regalia says that you should
not be wearing anything else on your
gown and I have to represent Yale Yale
College and you know the Residential
College I'm a fellow in you know Pearson
College
you'll see a lot of pins again and the
pins will as Virgie says represent
the Residential College or your school
yes whatever school is yours or whatever
college is yours yep I have the universe
the Yale College signia here
um our Yale chaplain's office we are our
University chaplain this is her final uh
University commencement and so I felt
I've had to wear a PIN to to honor her
service to the university and then I
work with a lot of our first generation
and low-income students and so I I honor
them with our why first pin because uh
this is a special moment for someone
who's worked very hard uh and is the
first in their family to attend college
and let alone graduate from a place like
Yale and you see that at the
undergraduate level but you also see it
at The Graduate and professional level
as well so now I'll also talk about
stalls which have become uh common in
the past only in the past 10 or 12 Years
first
I don't think we have a picture of the
kente Stalls I no idea and I did not
bring one but uh yeah so you know that
what we were seeing in this past couple
days we've held celebrations with some
of our cultural communities you know our
uh black undergraduate and graduate
students you know Latinos students uh
undergraduate graduate
um Asian Native American and so you'll
see uh students who will be coming
through uh who attended those elevations
who are involved in those Community
um and you'll see them you know so
you'll see a kente cloth stole for so
many of our students some of our
students will have uh the stole for La
Casa cultural of the Asian American
Cultural Center some students will have
stalls of uh their country you know so
they will particularly order a Honduran
flag or a Salvadoran flag so that they
can represent what is important uh you
may even see you know some of our native
Hawaiian students with days and other
things that are are you know signs of
Celebration
and what has become common in the past
you know number of years is people saw
all those stalls and the residential
colleges which they take great pride in
being
separate from each other the best
college you're in the best college is
yours have ordered stalls and I have
here the je stole the Jonathan Edwards
stole I was head of Jonathan Edwards
college and so aren't you responsible
for the colleges starting the stole
Trend I I think the scene rumor has it
that je may have broken the ice for all
the residential colleges that may be so
and if tomorrow
democratic failure
I'll I'll I'll get you out of town but I
will say
well sandwiches are very important
to graduates and so as a way of first of
all as a way of observing which college
is which when they process and also of a
certain amount of pride in them they
have become much more common almost all
the colleges now now have them and you
can identify the college by the color of
its stole we'll try to do that for you
as as we see them process each year
though you know you would see the
colleges and they all have their their
little extra you know a little bit of
flavor and I think you know the heads of
college work with their their student
leaders to kind of come up with
something so that you know you'll see
the Morse you know might have a a
hatchet you know with their Morse acts
that is part of their coat of arms for
the college
um so you know there'll be these little
things that will kind of distinguish
them Sons uh in sunflowers you know and
Pearson and other groups so it is this
idea of a way of celebrating uh the
colors The Pride and you know for the
undergraduates you know your residential
colleges your first kind of community
and so they want to make sure that they
are together some of the the
professional schools
also do things we'll see if they do
today
it's common that the school of
environment you'll see mortar boards
with a lot of flowers and grasses right
and things that signify the environment
you know the Divinity School often can
be seen with Halos on their caps not
every year nursing has its thing that it
does we'll see if it does it this year
it involves a lot of confetti yes they
are a celebratory group they work hard
and they are ready to celebrate the
moment
that now as far as as all this heraldry
grows why does Yale have so many banners
so many pins so many Shields what is it
not every College not even among our
peer institutions is that true
so it actually a lot of it goes back to
one man
his name is Theodore Sizer he was called
Tubby sizer
and he was one of the monument men one
of the men after World War II who was in
charge of identifying all of the
paintings and all of the sculptures that
the Nazis have removed from from museums
and had put in different places and it
took a team of art historians of which
Sizer was one of the most prominent wow
to uh discover these and to send them
back as much as possible not all of it
happened exactly as it should have but
as much as possible to where they
belonged so that was Professor Sizer he
was a professor of the history of Art
and he designed all of this celebratory
heraldry and regalia so he designed
every Banner you're going to see Banner
after Banner today and the banners will
identify the residential colleges the
banners will identify
the Prize winners the banners will
identify
the schools and all of this heraldry was
started by tubby Sizer they called him
tubby Sizer and he was called the
persuivant and that tradition has
continued all of the new colleges and
the new schools have heraldry that is
designed by John gamble the university
printer who has continued this great
tradition
so that Yale is just chock full of
banners and of heraldry of insignias
that identify the school or the college
so yesterday a class day I I was wearing
a hat that was designed by
um uh the spouse of a former dean of
Yale College and it was designed to
signify the expansion of Yale College
from 12 colleges to 14. so all the
shields of all 14 colleges are
represented on this ad and so I was
stopped along the walk by a couple of
alums who said uh Mr sizer's son was his
classmate in syllabus and so they wanted
a photograph with a hat to send to his
his Silliman friend to be able to say
your dad's work is being represented uh
at Yale College and so they were here
celebrating her graduate this weekend
one man that this all started he
designed the banners really using the
family insignias of the family Shields
of the People For Whom the colleges were
named they weren't all named for people
but uh cities uh the City of New Haven
John Davenport who just who actually
helped found the New Haven colony
and all of them
Jonathan Edwards looks like we've got
the uh clear there with the Yale mace
yeah so that mace there are many many
maces
um
and when I think of Mace you know you
think of that ball and chain with the
spikes on it but these are the flags of
the United States of the state of
Connecticut
um of the City of New Haven and um that
creature there with the horns that's the
Yale the Yale y-a-e-l Here Comes Tom
Duffy the leader of the band and in back
of him the band
there's they're marching off
and here's what's going to happen
friends
they are going to lead
the corporation party and all the honor
ends
to the green to the New Haven green
as I told you the center church was the
first place that Yale had its
commencement honoring that and honoring
its Origins and honoring the City of New
Haven so we have Timothy Dwight and
Sabra coming along I see the heads of of
the various colleges there with their
aces in hand
and they are going to surround the
undergraduate colleges are going to
surround the green
around Center Church and the corporation
party is going to move right through
them
so as you can see Timothy Dwight yep
Timothy Dwight and say Brooke and Sabra
no yeah no let's say Brooke on the right
this uh
theirs aren't all yellow though
yeah but you can see that it says on the
left side say Brooke there and so uh you
know they are as you can see the the
they've taken some of the Grapevine that
is in the
um
coat for say Brooke and they decorated
their motor boards in that way
Timothy Dwight with their red and white
colors and the and the crest there on
the other side so just to say what takes
so long here is that is that these
colleges are all going to surround the
New Haven green
by Center Church and the president's
party is going to March through them
and then the president's party with the
honorance will enter here
and all of the flags and Banners will
congregate by Phelps gate and we won't
be here then but the great moment the
very great moment is when all the flags
come down this aisle oh it's great
beautiful they're placed here in front
and they're placed in front and we have
Ezra Stiles and uh Solomon
uh coming along here Silliman always has
those noodles right the noodles and the
noise makers
Yep they're getting fired up
and after the
real colleges you will begin to see The
Graduate and professional schools so
first first the college is because
they're surrounding the green
and then the graduate and professional
schools will come and you'll see these
little little Traditions you know that
when I first came to Yale I had not seen
before but of you know the Tipping of
the cap so you know the dean of Yale
College Pericles Lewis is standing just
inside the gate there on the left-hand
side and as the heads of college you
know leave their colleges by they will
tip their cap to the dean and members of
the Yale College and they will return
the tip of the cap and so you'll see
this happening along the procession as
uh you know the faculty and Leadership
recognize each other as they make this
large procession Virgie let's talk a
little bit about the honorary degrees
now we're very lucky here because burgi
was at the honorary degree dinner last
night and he can tell us about several
of the honorary departments well it's
just I mean you know if you were
watching earlier that we were had some
of the images up of the degree
recipients Yale always has an amazing
array of uh you know people who receive
degrees here as honorary degrees and
president salave oh we got more some
Trumbull coming along here
I can see the new Dean of Morse we have
Blake Trimble and yeah a few other folks
but it it was just really wonderful to
see art music science literature all
represented in our degree recipients and
you'll hear more about them uh I had the
pleasure of sitting with Deborah Willis
who is an amazing photographer and uh
has really made a career around uh
storytelling through image
um particularly of the African-American
experience yeah and um you know we were
chatting about an experience I had when
I was a child on the Greyhound bus
traveling in the South and she was like
that's exactly the type of image that
I'm trying to capture and so
um she is so excited for this whole
experience so I think it's worth saying
a word about why we give honorary
degrees why do we do that and really
it's to honor those who have made a
great contribution to society and to set
that up as a kind of Exemplar for our
own graduates Yale has a great tradition
of public service and the hope is that
undergraduates will be inspired exactly
by seeing the honorary degree recipients
examples of people who have really kind
of walked the walk in life we have
Jonathan Edwards and Berkeley College
this is my college so yes yes she has to
take it in but that inspiration you know
and again at every level
our undergraduates are inspired by our
graduate students let me say a word
about the gowns you see gray with the
red bands that's MIT that's being worn
by Mark Saltzman
um Yale robe you see a lot of blue robes
yep and there's another Harvard uh Road
there and there's a Princeton robe black
with orange stripes is Princeton the
light blue is Columbia
um now we're seeing all students all our
students yeah from the college there so
faculty can March either with the
College of which they're a fellow or
they can march with The Graduate School
of Arts and Sciences
um
so but it is this you know but the
inspiration so I think our
undergraduates take inspiration from
seeing our our graduate and professional
students and you know from the faculty
and then you know the honorary degree
recipients really represent uh people
who have put this into action in in all
walks of life and are that inspiration
and so you you will see people who uh
you know in fact our class day speaker
yesterday Elizabeth Alexander yeah
um you know it was a yell it's a Yale
College alumna uh received an honorary
degree uh here a few years ago and again
she now runs the melon Foundation but
you know as a poet you know there were
students who were part of the party who
were saying I've been so inspired by
your work as a poet that it has inspired
me to continue in in writing in this way
and I knew Elizabeth when she was an
undergraduate here and then she stood up
and gave the poem at Obama's
along here so I see the Tina Lou the
head of uh Paulie Murray and their
Enrique and there you see the yellow
that's Johns Hopkins the yellow robe
um it looks like we have a purple robe
maybe I think that's an NYU robe
um
yeah among the honorary degree
are four people who previously had Yale
degrees yes so
probably the most well-known is Guido
calabresi the great jurist and great
teacher
uh and Paul jamati the actor the actor
yep who was an undergraduate here at
Yale and then got a degree from the
school of drama so he has two he has a
yearly through and through a new Havener
through and through his father was the
president of Yale Bart jamadi someone I
knew very well
and he the family has a long Yale
history
and then Elizabeth plated zyborg and
Andres dwani who have yeah yeah I mean
just you know their work in building
sustainable communities uh is just now
that is Saybrook I think
no we got Berkeley on the left is that
right no oh we have so it's still
Branford on the left and um no
oh that's right that's Branford yes yes
how could I miss that yeah I can't quite
make up the coat of arms on the right
there
that isn't Morse
a lot of them have red skulls yeah that
makes it harder to see
no that's still Polly Murray yeah
polymerase they have red with blue blue
yeah it's a light blue that's where I
could see it closely yeah I can't see
this too well so and then behind them is
Davenport and that's Berkeley
um and Berkeley uh and then Benjamin
Franklin I I must say you know one of
those things Franklin has blue yep and
so they're coming they're coming just
behind there yes you can see Jesse Hill
the dean and and Charles as uh I'm not
able to see this is the head of college
in each college dean Residential College
dean carries the maze Harry's a mace for
each of their residential cars so a word
about the Macy's we not only have all
this heraldry and all of these stalls
and
and Banners oh there's Jay gitlin and
all of these flags
but in addition
um
so the university mace weighs 24 pounds
we will see that coming along that is
carried every year by Lloyd Suttle
because we're you know you can't always
be sure that somebody is going to be
able to have 24 pounds as I say I think
Lloyd's so let's work it out to make
sure that he's he's ready to carry it on
the long journey so he carries the big
mates and then uh you will see that the
corporation is led by a retiring faculty
member Ed kamens professor of Japanese
literature language and literature who
will carry the corporation mace
and then coming down this aisle first
uh
at at some point when the president's
procession comes will become the senior
Marshal and that is Christine Hayes who
is retiring as a professor of religious
studies and then as Bergie said every
one of the colleges has a mace designed
for that college and you'll see them all
lined up here the maces and the flags
here at the front and you know again it
is you know basically as they say the
tribes gather here and so they plant
their flag to signify and you know the
students react to seeing their Mason
flag come in and whenever it goes by
even yesterday at the class day anytime
they saw their Deans or heads a huge
cheer would go up from their group so uh
we'll have the array of colors here in
front of us now we won't be hear when
this happens but after the president's
party comes down we're going to
disappear because they're going to come
up on the stage and we don't want to be
in this Pearson college that where I'm a
fellow I come there and left Steve Davis
the head of college is stepping down
there and then Grace Hopper there on the
right and
um the new head of Pearson will be uh
Crystal's theme sir yeah so folks are
very excited about Professor Finster and
she was actually recognized at the black
Graduate Ceremony the other night for a
distinguished in undergraduate teaching
to students in in the college and so she
received a special award it's a very
strong Steve has been a wonderful head
of college yes and being ahead of
college I can tell you I was one for
eight and a half years is a lot of work
because it falls on you and the dean to
make a home for your students and I
think you know given the size of Yale's
graduate programs that the Deans of the
school and have the same sense of family
has a great sense of family and the
pride in your special family is shown in
all of the heraldry and the marching
that you see and all of the banners but
even the you know the Deans and and uh
you know the the Deans and the staff and
the schools and professional schools you
can see they care deeply about their
students you know I was speaking to uh
James Bundy who's the dean of the Geffen
School for the Arts and drama drama and
you know just talking about you know
she's credit you can mention any student
so a neighbor of mine is a student in
his program and I I mentioned that and
he was like who and he knows exactly
what they're working on what kind of
projects they're doing uh because and
then even once they've moved out into
the world he is totally staying on top
and they recently visiting with some of
our alums in London uh who are doing
wonderful things in theater in the Arts
uh in in Europe
I think we
think people who are sitting here
waiting for the Grand Event to happen I
just want you to know that your your
students are very happy in what they're
doing uh they're marching they're
processing they're talking with one
another they're talking with faculty and
we know that you have a long wait uh but
we thank you for that and I know they
thank you for that
um but you know the the part of this
procession that I always kind of um
I just love is you know yes uh the
platform party steps off and the band
and you know and but when the
undergraduates come in they then make
that path around the even green and then
they split
and you know then you having these
people coming through the Middle where
it's wonderful that you know students
that I've known over the years during
their time at Yale I get to see them as
you know as I walk past the college and
it's so Virgie is saying that the Yale
College Dean's office you know forms
with students forms the
pathway and coming through will be the
president the corporation and the honor
ends not all of the honor ends are
always able to walk but many of them are
and
um it's it's a moment of
real intimacy and
makes you feel truly a part of the
ceremony when you see the President
coming down and the faculty tipping
their hats to him and his tipping his
hat to them and the honorans the special
honorance actually marching through you
so that's yeah you're like when are you
going to be you know that ain't got
proximity to an actor of apology I'm
naughty status or or Lonnie Bunch you
know the for the Smithsonian just one of
these people who is just
um
reshaped our American landscape in the
Arts and so literally they're passing uh
within feet and you're saying they're
coming to to celebrate and join in the
celebration of this special day so
another honorary degree recipient is is
Robert Carrow the great was he there
last night he was not there last night
he's
um not young but what a marvelous
biographer he is
um he wrote The Great biographies of
Robert Moses and of Lyndon Johnson which
I have read into the night the the Moses
one was is still mind-blowing it was one
of the my summer reads a couple years
ago and I was just blown away
Cairo has investigated every single
aspect of the lives of those great men
who transform each of whom transformed a
city and a country in different ways uh
and so he is receiving the honorary
degree
um and then Max Dale Cooper very
interesting the path path-breaking
scientist who invented the T Cell
discovered the T cells and the B cells
uh he was had an interesting background
he grew up in a rural uh rural
Mississippi in a junior college on a
football scholarship
and Rose to become one of the great
scientists of his age so yeah I mean you
know my mouth was just a gape as we were
listening to
um not only in conversation but just you
know the brief descriptions that
President saliva was was describing as
of some of the the the impact that these
folks have had and you know there are
various points of their career but you
know someone like you know president
Sullivan joked that you know there are a
few people who are known by one name you
know Madonna Cher Rihanna and Guido and
Greedo Calabrese was actually one of the
first people I met when I came to Yale
uh literally we arrived on a Saturday
night drove in from Chicago and we got
invited to a birthday party in Fairhaven
and on a Sunday and we said okay we'll
show up and I sat down at a picnic table
next to you know a gentleman and he just
said hi my name is Guida and I had no
idea that who he was and the impact he
had had on so Guido calabresi is I think
he's 91 or 92. uh he's still sitting on
the bench uh he just retired from
teaching at Yale and he will be a
community favorite uh here but um who
who haven't we talked about Francisco
Francis Cordoba yes so this is somebody
who is a great astrophysicist and a
great administrator and I've she's been
president of a college she's been
um head of Purdue director of the
National Science Foundation NASA's Chief
scientist and people talk of her as
someone with Big Ideas who is able to
put them into play and so she's not only
a serious astrophysicist but she's been
a person who has also been able to be
transformative as an administrator and
you know by when I was in the midwest I
mean you know she was one of those
people that everyone always spoke of in
terms of the leadership and really
making Purdue one of the Premier
researchers as president of Purdue yes
yeah
so uh just to say to go back to what
you're going to see when we're not
sitting here anymore after the
president's party comes when the flags
come down and here is a very interesting
point the Banners are carried by The
Prize winners and I always say that this
is Yale all over you win a big prize and
what do they do they make you carry a
heavy Banner all around the campus and
those Banners are not easy to carry well
and you know thankfully it is not a
terribly windy day here but if you are
uh kind of a slight person and there are
some who are yes it is uh they realize
that this honor comes with a bit of work
so they learn how to balance and uh you
know I'm sure everyone has they really
they're going to be a little bit sore
tomorrow when they wake up so when these
banners come down and that's after the
president's party and after we've left
the stage you'll see the U.S flag which
is carried by the Warren Prize winner
the Connecticut flag which is carried by
the Chittenden these are all
uh people who won High stand prizes the
president's Banner will be carried by
the southern Prize winners uh who are
the great undergraduate winners in the
Arts and then
um
you know then you'll see all of the
college Flags yeah the college flags and
and that's you'll hear a great cheer for
each of those College flags and then
you'll see each of the school flags and
when each of the schools sees its flag
they will give it a very big cheer and
that will be a beautiful sight coming
right down this middle aisle I think
you'll be able to see it on the screens
and new people yeah no capture at home
so you actually will able be able to see
it they'll have the best seat in the
house yeah and so you know the banners
and the flags and the maces are carried
by The Prize winners and by faculty who
are being especially honored on their
retirement
and I was
um at the final faculty meeting yeah
could you tell if I I was organizing
another event so I didn't get to go to
the fact if I could be hearing hearing
some of these wonderful tributes yeah so
the
the iris are given special tribute
and it really it's a very moving moment
you hear about the strength of each of
these people who have dedicated their
lives to Yale
people who have taught language senior
lectures as well as senior electors and
faculty there's a faculty member uh Bill
koenigsberg retiring The Sciences Who as
a youth he was a prodigy did two
remarkable things he invented Lubriderm
he invented something that was then sold
and and it was lubricant something that
I used this morning and he also invented
a coating for a bomb that kept it from
falling apart and so that it was
actually a contribution to World War II
he was that old because when the bomb
fell it did not crack into many many
pieces and that was a contribution he
did that as a very young man
and um I just love that that that final
faculty meeting takes place in
Connecticut Hall in the faculty room
where you've got the portraits of of the
past deans of Yale College in their Arts
and Sciences and it's just kind of such
a powerful moment oh oh so we can see
you see these are members of the Yale
College office yep George Levesque yeah
this is this is our beloved people here
yes
and now comes gosh I can't really see
this I think this is the uh this is
members of The Faculty so this is The
Graduate School yeah yeah these are all
members of the faculty and you get to
see a lot of the robes here
a lot of the light blue a lot of the the
purple the MIT Road Columbia Princeton
Johnson why are there with their
Princeton yeah Johns Hopkins
again more maces can't go anywhere
without a mace around here these days
University of Illinois
yep
and here come the the graduates so we
have
students from Arts and Sciences led by
Lynn Cooley the dean there and that is
that is the graduate school again and
then the school of medicine there on the
left uh
no yeah no the school of medicine's on
the left and School of Arts and Sciences
on the right
are they wearing the green yeah you can
see the green as they're starting to
come through there oh there they are
yeah
that's how fascinating that's a
fascinating gown that uh looks like
getting from a middle eastern Mia
University you see European gowns here
too from faculty yep so you see the blue
and the green so the students are
wearing the hoods of the degrees they
wore the faculty are wearing the grounds
the gowns of their highest degree so
seeing some of the kente cloth uh stalls
from students who participated in the
ceremony the other day at The Graduate
Ceremony
so again undergraduates graduates coming
together well they should be coming on
either side but the split doesn't happen
very well yeah now I see the green
stalls for the School of Medicine
our good friend Heather Calabrese is out
there directing traffic
she's the person in the white jacket
who's in charge of all of commencement
but you see you know the various chords
and different things that people that
again School Honors that uh
that looks like the flag of Yale College
nope that's the school of medicine flag
yeah no it's School medicine tomorrow
I'm having a hard time seeing you here
she's trying to keep the uh The Graduate
students yeah so that we have schools
separate yeah now public health public
health is salmon pink
do you see that yeah I'm just seeing I'm
seeing David paltiel there oh yeah and
so he's also affiliated with the school
of medicine but yep here comes in pink
full of Public Health
quite a few of them and the yellow are
science so they're part of the of the
graduate school and so there's a woman
there with a white stall from La Casa so
she attended the La Casa celebration for
our Latino students uh honoring them the
Stalls have really uh taken off but you
know what are the wonderful things that
happens at some of these ceremonies so I
was at the uh the the Latin celebration
after some prizes were announced and
there was a you know some celebration it
was basically an opportunity for parents
to get to the microphone to say
something to the audience and say
something to their student and you know
to have five minutes to express how
proud they are of their students that's
very nice you you wish it weren't so big
that every every family member couldn't
couldn't necessarily do that you know I
saw the other night the undergraduate uh
dramat performance of The Adams Family
and I'm going to tell you ladies and
gentlemen and friends and neighbors that
that was a fantastic performance the
level of talent there was also on
Saturday night with the heimowitz
brothers
um tap danced to a cello
um really yeah to a Chopin cello piece
so that the the incredible undergraduate
performance in the Arts
may not be exactly the same as the
professional schools of the Arts but
they are very very living with Talent
very very fine so we're still with
Public Health
on the left and was still The Graduate
School which is very very big of course
so some of our our honored some school
of medicine is making its way into the
yard here to our right yeah so the
school of medicine will sit
here comes the flag of the school of
medicine I don't know if you can see it
no no it's not on camera it's just
pointing it out to our right we're still
seeing that those many public health
grads that we were talking about coming
through and and we will not see all the
graduate schools because when the
president's party comes down here we we
will be gone but uh just to tell all of
you
I'm going to tell you where everybody's
going to be sitting and even you
watching virtually will will be able to
see
medicine
and public health and law and nursing
and art and architecture and drama will
be over there okay okay over there
and over here
will be Divinity music
Yale School of Engineering
The Graduate School and Jackson will be
over here excellent yeah
yep The Faculty are starting to fill in
the faculty is beginning to come in good
morning everybody
you can hear a little bit of a buzz in
the back as among the families as they
start to see the first of the flags
start to arrive coming through Phelps
gate
so this is the school of medicine which
is yep you can see some of the graduates
entering coming through Phelps gate and
for many you know college students this
is the entry point into their Yale
we say Dr fauciology
so you know we see you know the
undergrad starting to file in we see
some of the graduate and professional
Schools starting to file in
and again you know folks are you know if
you're watching at home you know folks
are starting to get on their feet you
know they're warming up their their
phones and tablets to kind of capture
the moment of seeing their graduate
moving in
and luckily apoli the
I hope everybody was within sight of one
of them of the big screen so that they
can actually get a close look at what is
going on we've got the School of Nursing
coming along there on the left-hand side
I think they don't they sit over there
well they're still coming through the
gate so they've got a little ways to go
they're carrying their mace
and I think that's the Jackson School
there on the right
it's interesting in their coat of arms
that the little uh yellow is kind of uh
like a glow yeah an ancient Globe but
also a compass so it's an ancient uh for
navigating kind of global affairs
um so that was built into that heraldry
there's David Simon that is the peacock
blue all right that's what peacock blew
that's what peacock blue is so that is
is nursing is all you know tricked out
they have the orange
um uh hoods for the School of Nursing
yep
they're often carrying things I'm sure
they are they've got streamers and I see
the graduate school yesterday
is here good morning
and the faculty from The Graduate School
are entering now
lots of Celebration you know one of my
favorite things you know so the Yale
College Dean's office sets up right
inside just inside no reporter gate and
you know many of the as you mentioned
earlier on all the in all the
residential colleges the staff are
preparing getting ready for the the
diploma ceremonies and they're getting
food ready and they're busying in the
college and so many of them are maybe
watching us on the live stream right now
but Berkeley because of its position
gets to come out onto the little porch
That's right near where we are and when
their graduates go past they go nuts and
you know one of the things it's the
students realize that they these are the
people who have taken care of them for
the past four years and they are so
grateful to the dining staff the
housekeeping staff the the office the
OMS and it's it's a really wonderful
kind of celebration in send-off uh for
this uh this is the Jackson School mace
it must be that's being put in the front
here
yeah a new mace uh we have the School of
Art coming through the gate now
and they're very they have a very
beautiful colorful flag the School of
Art has they were in the brown hoods and
they have a very colorful beautiful flag
uh their Banner is lovely this is uh
Divinity is on the right it's my
graduate assistant there Infinity this
is the second oldest school at Yale I
used to think it was the oldest but the
school of medicine was the oldest School
founded at Yale and
yes
and number two actually is the school of
divinity it's of course originally Yale
was founded to educate clerics and
people for civil state so in a sense it
was itself a Divinity School at the
beginning but uh the actual School
itself was founded
um so you see the Divinity students
there with their red uh hoods
and here with the purple hoods the light
purple the light purple is architecture
architecture yeah yeah architecture
light purples architecture
um you know one thing we didn't discuss
is when you see the president he's going
to be wearing a big collar
and that collar has a big jewel in the
middle and it has Lux and veritas on it
it's a beautiful thing and it has light
and truth and it has examples of the
graduate schools and the undergraduate
school on this collar he wears and this
is the second caller the first collar
was unfortunately stolen from a vault in
1979. so a great robbery huh this is the
the second
and by the way on the stage here in the
in the back of the stage will be sitting
a maritai all of the ameritai are given
an honored place on the stage uh who
agree to come to commencement
and in front of us we have the faculty
which is only fitting that you know
these are the folks who have led this
process yes
um and uh you know celebrate our
honorary degree recipients and work with
their Deans
now is this a darker purple or is this
where's that russet is
purple still on the left and then we've
got pink so that must be the school
school of music yeah
yeah
the School of Architecture and the
School of Music
and again selfies photographs of the
moment capturing it live streaming you
know sometimes you'll see a student with
a GoPro uh camera capturing the entire
procession
um
and particularly for folks at home you
know that I know that when we do these
live stream events either for family
weekend or for this event we've got
people tuning in from Australia and
Karachi and Istanbul uh just because it
may be so far for so many family members
to travel but frequently you know people
try to have at least one or two family
members here uh to celebrate this very
special moment
yeah
oh now it's beginning to fill up we've
got Divinity on the left here is coming
in
low divinity
ready to go they're ready to go
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
these are the people who are going to be
taking good care of us in the future
yeah
mind body and spirit I think is what we
got going on here
and I have to say that by
uh waiting for JE is I see cam Edwards
this is Kim I think is 93 or 94. he
graduated in the class of 1949 and he
has taken sat in on
150 courses so after he retired he came
to Yale and he started taking courses
and here he is in his early 90s at the
Yale commencement so we
his
who else is coming in now here comes I
think Public Health yep and so you know
we are going to be
shifting so that the camera can see
Penny the camera is going to be able to
see that you know the president's
reception and we're going to be wrapping
up our time here so that people can take
in the moment and so thank you very much
for joining us yeah and remember the
president's party is going to come down
and then you're going to wait and you're
going to see all the flags coming down
and you're going to know what they are
so happy commencement to everybody thank
you folks enjoy the day
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
thank you
how'd you get over here
okay okay that was good okay that was
good
thank you
purchase something
is
done yeah
yes
I think the military academy
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you foreign
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Crown Imperial
s
[Applause]
hi again
if not it's not worth it
okay
right
[Music]
thank you
come on
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
okay
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
other stuff
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
concussion ready and
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
happy birthday
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
students of the class of 2023
and their parents families and friends
welcome
to the
322nd commencement of Yale University
We Gather to recognize the extraordinary
accomplishments of all of you
all of you who have worked so hard to
complete your programs of study
We Salute your effort your diligence
your talent and your intellect
we also join you in expressing gratitude
for all who have supported you in these
endeavors
your families and friends
[Applause]
your teachers and other members of the
Yale community
[Applause]
in keeping with the tradition of this
occasion
I now call on the University chaplain to
offer an invocation
now
with deep gratitude
to the Quinnipiac people for this land
on which we stand my beloved Yale family
I invite you to join me in the spirit of
Prayer
Almighty and loving creator
you are the force that lights the Stars
the architect of every cell the source
of all truth
we stand in the dazzling beauty of this
morning as many living expressions of
one mystery
a mystery beyond all telling
we who share this beautiful but aching
world
we who look at the same sun and the same
moon are a people called to communal
restoration
as students of your handiwork we have
gathered here from throughout the Earth
with exquisite Ambitions and have been
blessed at this place of light and Truth
with the freedom to let them grow
Our God of all generations you are the
guardian of where we are going and who
we are becoming
as we prepare to take leave of this
place
may we exude an intelligence that is
inspired by Justice
Guided by tenderness
moved by Holiness and always always
informed by love
from this moment of awe and Beyond
fill our hearts with an imaginative
daring one that stirs us to become
vibrant living examples of Shalom of
Salam of Shanti
of peace
together
let us say
amen
please be seated
Mr President
I have the honor to present candidates
for the bachelor's degree in Yale
College for the degree of Bachelor of
Science of Arts 839 in number and for
the degree of Bachelor of Science
562 in number they have been recommended
by The Faculty of Yale College and
approved by the corporation I now ask
you by your official act to confer upon
them these degrees
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
by the authority
by the authority vested in me I confer
upon you the bachelor's degrees in Yale
College
as designated by the dean and admit you
to all their rights and responsibilities
[Applause]
[Music]
congratulations
[Applause]
[Music]
congratulations
[Applause]
and congratulations
Mr President I have the honor to present
candidates for degrees in the School of
Architecture
for the degree
laughs
for the degree master of architecture 97
in number
and for the degree master of
environmental design three in number
they have been recommended by The
Faculty of the school and approved by
the corporation I now ask you by your
official act to confer upon them these
degrees
by the authority vested in me I confer
upon you the degrees in architecture and
design as designated by the dean and
admit you to all their rights and
responsibilities
congratulations
[Applause]
Mr President
I have the honor to present candidates
for degrees in the School of Art
for the
for the degree of Master of Fine Arts 61
in number
they have been recommended by The
Faculty of the school and approved by
the corporation I now ask you
by your official act to confer upon them
this degree
by the authority vested in me I confer
upon you the degree in arts as
designated by the dean and admit you to
all its rights and responsibilities
[Applause]
[Music]
congratulations
[Applause]
Mr President
I have the honor to present candidates
for degrees in the David Geffen School
of drama
[Music]
for the certificate in drama one in
number
for the degree of Master of Fine Arts 53
in number and for the degree of doctor
of Fine Arts to a number
they have been recommended by The
Faculty of the school and approved by
the corporation I now ask you by your
official act to confer upon them these
degrees
by the authority vested in me I confer
upon you the certificate and degrees in
drama as designated by the dean and
admit you to all their rights and
responsibilities
congratulations
[Music]
Mr President
I have the honor to present candidates
for the degrees in the School of Music
for certificate in performance one in
number for the degree of Master Of Music
73 in number
for the degree of Master of musical arts
39 in number and for the degree doctor
of musical arts six in number
they have been recommended by The
Faculty of the school and approved by
the corporation I now ask you by your
official act to confer upon them these
degrees
by the authority vested in me I confer
upon you the certificate diploma and
degrees in music as designated by the
dean and I admit you to all their rights
and responsibilities
congratulations
[Applause]
Mr President
I have the honor to present candidates
for the degrees in the School of Nursing
[Applause]
for the degree of master of science in
nursing
101 in number
for the postgraduate APRN certificate in
nursing three in number
for the doctor for the degree of doctor
of nursing practice 21 in number
they have been recommended by The
Faculty of the school and approved by
the corporation I now ask you by your
official act to confer upon them these
degrees
by the authority vested in me I confer
upon you the certificate and degrees in
nursing as designated by the dean and
admit you to all their rights and
responsibilities
[Music]
congratulations
[Applause]
Mr President I have the honor to present
candidates for degrees in the school of
the environment
[Applause]
for the degree of Master of
Environmental Management 87 in number
environmental science 36 in number for
the degree of Master of Forestry nine in
number and for the degree of Master of
forest science two in number
they have been recommended by The
Faculty of this school and approved by
the corporation I now ask you by your
official act to confer upon them
these degrees
[Applause]
by the authority vested in me I confer
upon you the degrees in environment and
Forestry as designated by the dean and
admit you to all their rights and
responsibilities
[Applause]
thank you congratulations
congratulations
congratulations oh thank you so much
thank you appreciate that
Mr President
I have the honor
to present candidates for degrees in the
School of Management
for the degree of Master of Business
Administration
398 in number
for the degree of Master of advanced
management
52 in number
and for the degree of Master and
management studies
111 in number
they have been recommended by The
Faculty of the school
and approved by the corporation
I now ask you by your official act to
confer upon them
these degrees
[Applause]
by the authority vested in me I confer
upon you the degrees in management as
designated by the dean and admit you to
all their rights and responsibilities
[Applause]
congratulations
Mr President
I have the honor to present candidates
for degrees in the Divinity School
for the degree of master of arts in
religion 56 in number for the degree of
Master of divinity 51 in number for the
degree of Master of sacred theology 12
in number
they have been recommended by The
Faculty of the school and approved by
the corporation I now ask you by your
official act to confer upon them
these degrees
by the authority vested in me I confer
upon you the degrees in religion
Divinity and theology as designated by
the dean and admit you to all their
rights and responsibilities
congratulations
thank you
Mr President I have the honor to present
degrees candidates for the degrees in
the law school
[Applause]
[Music]
for the degree of Juris doctor
220 in number
for the degree of Master in laws 22 and
number and for the degree of Master of
studies in law one in number
when they have been recommended by The
Faculty of the school and approved by
the corporation I shall ask you by your
official act to confer upon them these
degrees
by the authority vested in me I shall
confer upon you the degrees in the law
school when designated by the dean and
shall then admit you to all their rights
and responsibilities
congratulations
great
Mr President I have the honor to present
candidates for degrees in The Graduate
School
for the master for the degree of master
of science
342 in number for the degree of master
of arts
247 in number for the degree of Master
of philosophy
384 in number
they have been recommended by The
Faculty of the school and approved by
the corporation I now ask you by your
official act to confer upon them these
degrees
by the authority vested in me I confer
upon you the degrees in The Graduate
School as designated by the dean and
admit you to all their rights and
responsibilities
[Applause]
Mr President
I have the honor to present candidates
for degrees in the School of Public
Health
for the degree of Master Public Health
390 in number they have been recommended
by The Faculty of the school and
approved by the corporation
I now ask you by your official act to
confer upon them this degree
[Music]
[Applause]
by the authority vested in me
I confer upon you the degree in public
health as designated by the dean and
admit you to all its rights and
responsibilities
congratulations
[Applause]
[Music]
Mr President I have the honor to present
candidates for degrees in the school of
medicine
[Applause]
for the degree of Master of Medical
Science 119 in number when they have
been recommended by The Faculty of the
school and approved by the corporation I
shall ask you by your official act to
confer upon them this degree
for the certificate in global medicine
three in number
for the degree of Master of Health
Science 35 in number and for the degree
of doctor of medicine 107 in number
they have been recommended by The
Faculty of the school and approved by
the corporation I now ask you by your
official act to confer upon them these
degrees
but
by the authority vested in me
I shall confer the degree in medical
science and do confer upon you the
certificate in global medicine and
degrees in health science and medicine
as designated by the dean and admit you
to all their rights and responsibilities
congratulations
[Music]
and congratulations
Mr President
I have the honor to present candidates
for degrees in the Jackson School of
global affairs
for the degree of Master in public
policy 29 in number and for the degree
of Master of advanced study nine in
number
they have been recommended by The
Faculty of the school and approved by
the corporation
I now ask you by your official act to
confer upon them these degrees
by the authority vested in me I confer
upon you the degrees in global Affairs
as designated by the dean and admit you
to all their rights and responsibilities
[Applause]
congratulations
prices Clarissa May
candidatos and gratam philosophy I dris
numero quadrangante triganta quincue TB
presento a facultate philosophy artium
[Music]
academic illustri aprivati soon
k gratam admitas
[Applause]
[Music]
nostray
was
spectant confero
nank
study is for look at their absoluties
ego
prices
was at X Amano Yobe
salware
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
my people all of us
[Music]
we praise
we will now proceed to the awarding of
honorary degrees
the nine individuals we honor this
morning serve as examples to you
our graduates to encourage you to Aspire
to Excellence
to Value those elements of human
character that they embody creativity
curiosity discipline integrity and a
passion for public service
their presence here also honors you
you who graduate today and all of us who
are here to salute you
I will now as is customary call upon the
Provost to present the candidates for
honorary to grief
Mr President
I have the honor to present the
candidates for honorary degrees
for the degree of doctor of science
France a Cordova science administrator
prominent astrophysicist and
transformative administrator again and
again
you have fostered collaboration and
Innovation as the Director of the
National Science Foundation
NASA's Chief scientist president of
Purdue University
and in many other leadership roles
your consummate abilities as galvanizer
and champion of scientific progress
have expanded the frontiers of
possibility and enabled breakthroughs
that enrich our lives
Stellar scientists and administrator the
Earth and Heavens rejoice
as we recognize you with this doctor of
Science degree
[Applause]
[Music]
for the degree of doctor of letters
Robert Allen Carrow biographer
brilliant chronicler of Robert Moses and
president Lyndon Johnson
you have immersed yourself in historical
research pursued every lead
and explored every line of every source
to illuminate two of the most
complicated and multi-faceted
personalities of our age
with integrity and perseverance you've
devoted your life's work to reveal the
mechanisms of power
through an intimate understanding of
those who wield it
for Illuminating the way in which
galvanizing figures have shaped our
society
we are honored to welcome you into the
Yale family with the doctor of letters
degree
[Applause]
for the degree of doctor of Humane
letters Lani G Bunch III Museum
administrator and educator
Secretary of the Smithsonian Institution
renowned historian and bold educator
you are the Visionary force in
establishing the national museum of
African-American history and culture
[Applause]
a museum whose Holdings remind us that a
people's journey is a nation's story
your accomplishments as curator and
leader are matched only by your passion
for preserving the stories that need to
be told heard and remembered
guardian of Our National Treasures
We Lift Every Voice as we declare you
yourself a National Treasure and proudly
confer on you the degree of doctor of
Humane letters
congratulations thank you
[Applause]
for the degree of doctor of laws Guido
calabresi judge and legal scholar
thank you
groundbreaking scholar eminent jurist
fabled teacher and beloved Dean your
students have gone on to shape a nation
no last name needs to be appended to
your first when it is used in legal
circles across the globe the name Guido
says it all
the field of law owes much to you son of
Italy your second country America owes
much to you
and no entity owes more to you than your
University which takes pride in
exclaiming
complimenty as it confers on a champion
of Justice his third Yale degree
congratulations
for the degree of doctor of Fine Arts
Andres M dewani and Elizabeth plater
zyberg
architects
from the quarters of this campus to the
sidewalks of Seaside and Beyond
yours is an architectural Partnership of
enduring impact
together you saw the potential for
building pedestrian friendly
environments and communities that Foster
connection
and your masterful designs have brought
that Vision to fruition and
revolutionized practices worldwide
Transformers of town planning for
renewing our concept of the urban
environment and for advocating smart
growth and walkable cities
over unsustainable sprawl we proudly
present you both with your second Yale
degrees doctor of Fine Arts
[Applause]
for the degree of doctor of medical
Sciences Max Dale Cooper immunologist
path-breaking scientist born and raised
in rural Mississippi
you began your education on a football
scholarship in a community college and
have risen to make transformative
discoveries to human knowledge
your revelation of the unique functions
of T cells and B cells and of a
separately evolved immune system in
primitive vertebrates laid the
foundation for advances in modern
medicine
that have saved and improved countless
lives
change maker for Human Health and
Longevity
We join a grateful chorus as we Grant
you the Yale degree of doctor of medical
Sciences
congratulations
[Applause]
for the degree of doctor of humanities
Deborah Willis artist and author
[Music]
photographer and Sublime visual artist
with a Keen Eye and a deep sense of
context
you've given us a legacy of images that
explore document and celebrate the
African American Experience
with indomitable will you have labored
to preserve the memorable work of
artists who otherwise might have been
lost to history
for reframing our perceptual
understanding and helping us to see
better that visual culture can play a
part in social change
Yale is privileged to confer on you the
degree of doctor of humanities
congratulations
for the degree of doctor of Fine Arts
Paul Giamatti actor
whether on stage at the Yale rep
or on screens around the world
your gift is an actor confers looks and
lends wear a test to every role you
inhabit
you have brought to life a curmudgeonly
connoisseur
a modern day Prince of Denmark an
eccentric writer and a founding father
son of a Yale president whose name
reverberates in our Halls
gifted artist whose work is watched by
billions
they're catching on
we don't speak sideways but with
directness
when we say we take pride and pleasure
in honoring you with your third yelder
degree
doctor of Fine Arts
congratulations
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
through science
[Music]
the truth is
foreign
[Music]
until the Lord
is true
[Music]
I invite you to join with me in a
closing prayer for the graduates
god without transition
on this day of our transition
we celebrate the deserved achievements
of all graduates and honorees
achievements elevated by persistence
through a grueling
and deadly pandemic
give all whom we celebrate
a moral compass to serve causes larger
than their own
intuitive glimpses
into what can be
rather than what is
in continued perseverance
to pursue their Visions in the face of
recalcitrant resistance
bless
the families and friends who sustained
their past
this University that has shaped their
present
and above all the graduates who will
build a future
for us all all men
[Music]
thank you
no no no no no no no no
no
no no no no
no no
no no no no no no no no no no no
thank you
[Music]
no
thank you
[Music]
or something
thank you
[Music]
foreign